Lenny wrote in and said what something
you did as a kid that you still feel bad
about now okay so I've told the story
before and I know when I tell it some
people really their view of me changes
and I feel like I always tell the story
Pat in a way where I think that it was
really an example of someone really
learned learning and growing and this
story something I still really feel bad
about is that when I was in seventh
grade I had very little understanding of
uh discrimination against LGBT
individuals I had very limited
understanding of what it even means to
throw around words like that's gay or
you're a [ __ ] uh and there was an
incident where in seventh grade French
class there was a kid there and he was
bugging me doing something with my
backpack kicking my seed I don't
remember what it was and I don't
remember everything that was said in
this exchange but I turned around and I
said something about his [ __ ] hair and
I had no idea what the implications of
that were I had no idea that there was
at particularly at the time this was
many years ago such a heated debate over
LGBT rights and legislation and
discrimination and it uh this individual
reported it and uh I was sent down to
the principal's office as they say and I
was suspended for a day and very quickly
after that my parents had a conversation
with me and I was told very clearly you
know whatever you meant by that and
clearly I didn't mean anything I didn't
identify the individual as as being a
gay person right it was just something
that I thought of to say without
understanding what the meaning was
that's not something that has no meaning
that is really significant meaning that
impacts people in a real way of course
since then very few years later I mean I
think I was 12 at the time by the time I
was 14 or 15 I strongly considered
myself an LGBT ally and of course I
ultimately ended up being you know a
media partner for glad and and doing so
many other things that most inner
audience are aware of I still feel bad
about that even though I didn't mean it
as I see you as a
gay person and being gay is bad which is
sometimes what is meant when someone
insults someone else it by saying the
word [ __ ] to this day I still feel bad
about it and what happened a few years
ago in this part I may not never have
added on facebook the person I said this
to when I was 12 came up as a suggested
friend and as soon as I saw their name
pop up I sent them a message immediately
saying you know I still think about this
incident and I feel really bad and I
don't know if I ever apologize i think i
did but this is an apology as an adult
for what i said and i never hear heard
back from them and i still might my
senses i don't know if my email because
we weren't connected on Facebook went
into their filtered folder which often
happens or if they saw the message and
just didn't want to hear from me because
they're still mad at me but I still feel
bad about that incident but I think it
has a lot to do with the fact that even
10 20 years ago there wasn't much
education towards LGBTQ issues now
classroom not only would need have even
be it been aware of some of the stuff uh
they used to be this uh disick waiting
of the word gay too stupid right that
seems to be going away someone would say
that's so gay when they mean to say it's
dumb is it going away I think for the
most part it's it's going away at least
I in my circles haven't been hearing it
very much that's good yeah the other one
is and I've mentioned this one before
Louis and I former producer Louis and I
who grew up together in the winter we
used to hide behind my mom's house and
try to time throwing snowballs over the
house to land on cars and that I
actually don't feel that bad about but
when the snow melted one of us got the
brilliant idea to say well there's no
more snow will just throw rocks we did
that a couple times and that ended
pretty quickly and thinking now someone
who drives around in a car if an 11 year
old or 10 year old threw rocks at my car
and it hurt sounded like gravel raining
on my on my hood uh I would be pretty
upset about that and I regret that fully
and I would not do that and I'd be
furious if I had a kid and they were
doing that that's the other one that I
can remember